When they were about to face down all manner
of things worse than anyone’s deepest, darkest
nightmares, Alex and the rest of the team
did what they could to keep their spirits
up.
There was an old song they used to hum whenever
heading on missions, the low sound of that
tune giving them just a marginal boost to
their morale.
It never did all that much to numb the sense
of impending doom the team all collectively
felt, but it was better than sitting in a
transport unit in silence, letting the dread
get to them.
Even though it had been a while since Mobile
Task Force Epsilon had been dispatched on
their current assignment, and they had hummed
it together as they shipped out, Alex found
himself trying to remember the words to that
old song.
‘Smile through your fear and sorrow, then
maybe tomorrow you'll see the sun come shining
through.’
It was pretty hard for Alex to keep a smile
on his face after losing so many of his teammates…
and seeing what The Grinner had done to them.
The trail had gone cold again, much to the
disdain of the team’s commanding officer.
Receiving a number of new sightings and witness
reports, the SCP Foundation had sent the remaining
members of MTF Epsilon – also known under
the code name ‘Tyrfing Black’ – out
on another hunt for SCP-4910.
The creature had been at large for years now,
with every attempt the Foundation had made
to capture it ending in grisly, gut-churning
failure.
Fifty-seven separate times they had sent their
personnel after this anomaly on the loose,
and not all of them had come back.
Although Alex often found himself thinking
of the ones that had returned, and seeing
photos of how they had changed in the after-action
reports.
Not to mention the bodies.
Those that made it back ended up looking virtually
unrecognizable as human beings.
After having seen what happened to them, maybe
it was better not to know what gruesome fate
had befallen the ones who were still missing
in action, he told himself, keeping that train
of thought private.
Tracking SCP-4910 brought its own plethora
of issues; naturally, or the Foundation would
have it secured by now.
The creature had some way of interfering with
recording devices, rendering them completely
useless.
And of course, that meant that Tyrfing Black
had little to no clue what the monster actually
looked like.
Given that it disrupted any and all recording
equipment, including cameras and audio devices,
the Task Force’s hands were somewhat tied.
It forced Alex and his teammates to try and
locate it through more old-fashioned means,
following up on eyewitness reports, a lot
of which led them to a dead end.
Every now and then, however, one of these
sightings would prove to be genuine.
The quickest way to tell was usually if a
person living near the place where a report
came in from had gone missing lately.
Civilians were SCP-4910’s main source of
food, and a recent disappearance in the area,
paired with a sighting of something large
and four-legged, usually meant the beast had
come out of hiding to feed again.
“Alright, listen up team!”
Commanding Officer Sawyer announced.
With the level of militaristic speed and discipline
expected of them by the Foundation, Alex and
the other members of the Mobile Task Force
quickly filed out of the transport and fell
in, ready and waiting to receive their orders.
“Now, you all know the reason why we’re
here,” Sawyer strode back and forth, arms
behind his back as he addressed what was left
of his unit; three operatives, not including
himself.
“Even so, it’s imperative you don’t
forget it either.
So, these are the facts.
To date, the anomaly designated as SCP-4910
is still running wild.
But if we have anything to say about it, then
that sucker won’t be running for much longer!”
The three troops gave a quick chant in agreement,
although Alex kept quiet, just mouthing along.
He wasn’t exactly sure that they would actually
ever catch up to The Grinner.
So little file footage of the monster even
existed, meaning the team still had little
to no clue what this thing was, or if they
were even equipped to fight it.
And then again, a huge part of him didn’t
want to ever find SCP-4910, knowing what it
had done to the fallen former members of Mobile
Task Force Epsilon.
“So, here’s the latest,” Commander Sawyer
continued, silencing the team.
“Approximately twelve hours ago, we received
a message from one of the Foundation’s field
operatives.
This agent has been in deep cover living in
a nearby town for a number of years.”
As he spoke, the commanding officer gestured
down the high ridge that they had landed on.
Far below, sitting in the center of a huge
dip in the earth, was a small township.
There was barely enough room for more than
a few hundred people at most.
All around the small urban center, bordering
the entire town in an almost perfect circle,
was a dense forest.
It was an ideal cover for the monster, and
Alex could see on his teammate’s faces that
they all knew it too.
With them in the town, there was no way they
could cover every possible avenue of approach.
“This operative, is he the one that called
in the eyewitness report?”
one of the team, Warren, piped up and asked.
“That’s correct, Agent Warren,” Sawyer
confirmed.
“That agent has agreed to meet us at a rendezvous
a few clicks north of here.
The four of us will circumnavigate the town,
stick to the cover of these woods as we head
out to make contact with him.
From there, he’ll guide us to where the
creature was sighted.”
The team gave little response, just a few
low murmurs expressing their collective apprehension.
In a strange way, Alex found it comforting
that, at the very least, he wasn’t the only
one having some serious reservations about
potentially coming face to face with SCP-4910.
“Now, boys,” their commander sighed.
“I get it.
All of us have been trying to catch this freak
for a long while, and we’ve lost a lot of
good people from our unit along the way.
But we are Tyrfing Black, you hear me?
You all know what that name means.
Tyrfing, as in the sword from Norse Mythology,
cursed to kill every time it was drawn.
And that’s us, that is exactly what we’re
going to do when we finally find that monster.
For all our fallen brothers and sisters.
By the time we’re through with it, The Grinner
will be smiling out of the other side of its
ugly face.
Now, let’s move out, double time!”
With a half-hearted cheer, the squad prepared
to start their hike through the forest that
encircled the town.
The four survivors of Mobile Task Force Epsilon
fanned out, keeping close enough to see and
hear each other, but not too close that they
were clustered together.
The more they huddled up, the easier it would
be to take them out if The Grinner was able
to get the jump on them.
Although he should have been keeping his eyes
forward, looking out for any tracks the creature
might have left, Alex couldn’t help checking
over his shoulder.
The sun was getting lower and lower in the
sky, the day rapidly turning to night.
Before long, their visibility would be compromised,
severely limited by the lack of natural light.
It was then he looked to his fellow team members,
Warren and Jones; besides Alex himself and
the squad’s commander, they were the only
other Tyrfing Black operatives left.
Warren had always been the more brash and
outspoken of the group, willing to stand up
and question the orders of Commanding Officer
Sawyer.
Alex could tell Warren was having the same
worries about this plan as he was.
The thick tree line gave them plenty of cover,
but could also easily work to the monster’s
advantage, allowing it to sneak up and get
the drop on the team with relative ease.
But both Alex and Warren also knew that, if
the MTF was pushed back towards the town,
they would be trapped, like fish in a barrel,
just waiting to be picked off by SCP-4910.
Jones was walking slightly ahead of the others,
his gaze rapidly scanning back and forth across
the forest before them.
He was the team’s most accomplished tracker,
meaning he was always on the lookout for anything
that could give them a better idea as to where
the Grinner was heading, or if it was nearby.
From scratches on tree bark, to sets of inhuman,
unnatural footprints belonging to a large,
quadruped beast, and, of course, trails of
blood or bodies, if there was a sign, Jones
would find it.
Much like Alex, the other two operatives had
become more than a little jaded with their
ongoing hunt for the elusive entity.
But on top of that, not that either one of
them would admit it to the others, they were
scared of it too.
The things this creature was capable of were
enough to make anyone think twice about wanting
to find it.
As much to quell his own fear and sorrow,
as well as that of his teammates, Alex started
humming the tune to Smile, just loud enough
for them to hear, but quiet enough – he
hoped – to not draw any unwanted attention.
It was already dark by the time Tyrfing Black
were beginning to approach the coordinates
where they had arranged to meet the Foundation
agent.
Commander Sawyer had given his troops a silent
hand signal, and all of them had lowered the
night vision goggles affixed to their helmets.
Through the fuzzy green hue of the optics,
Jones was the first to spot a figure leaning
against a tree, waiting for them in the distance.
“Sir,” he whispered to Sawyer, catching
his attention and then making a gesture towards
the vaguely human shape in the shadows ahead
of them.
Looking to where Jones had pointed, Alex and
Warren could see the agent waiting for them.
Following their commander’s lead, they paced
steadily towards the undercover operative…
it was only as they stepped closer that they
realized he wasn’t moving.
“Agent Manning?”
Sawyer called out to him, trying to keep his
voice as hushed and low as possible.
No response, Manning was still, propped up
against a tree trunk.
The team were a few feet from him now, while
the commander stepped up to the agent and
turned him around by his shoulder…
only to recoil at what he saw.
Manning’s eyes were open but remained unblinking
and lifeless.
But that was far from the worst thing that
had happened to his face.
A huge, disproportionate grin had stretched
his mouth wider than was natural.
Masses of jagged, uneven teeth had taken root,
pushing out from under his tongue and the
roof of his mouth, filling his airway with
thick clusters of yellowy white enamel.
There were so many new teeth sprouting from
Manning’s face that new fixed and unsettling
smiles had started to form, splitting open
his cheeks.
“Back, back!” Sawyer told his men in an
urgent, hushed whisper.
“Remember boys, we don’t know how contagious
this thing is.”
Given they had never seen it in the flesh,
that was true.
All the previous failed attempts at bringing
in SCP-4910 had ended with victims displaying
similar signs of some unknown anomalous infection.
Whatever it was, it seemed to spread from
the creature itself, causing a human being
to overproduce masses of teeth.
This started with new clusters of dentins
painfully tearing through the mouth until
the victim could no longer speak or breathe
properly.
If given enough time, teeth would begin forming
elsewhere on the body, below the neck in places
they shouldn’t be.
The lucky ones – not that there were many
of them – had managed to get themselves
medical attention soon after they had been
exposed.
Within an hour, maybe two at best, of an encounter
with SCP-4910, there was still a chance of
saving one of its victims through intensive
dental surgery.
But three or four hours afterward, and it
would already be too late.
Hearing the distant snap of a twig, Jones
turned with his weapon raised, arms locked
in a combat-ready stance.
“Possible contact,” he declared, aiming
his gun into the deep, shadowy forest.
Matching his bearing and targeting the same
area, Sawyer gave a hand signal to Alex and
Warren, urging them to lock and load.
Lifting their rifles, they covered the opposite
direction, just in case someone, or something
came dashing out of the forest at them from
the other direction.
For a few moments, everything was still, although
certainly not calm in the least part.
Feeling a bead of sweat crawl down the back
of his neck, Alex lifted a hand to wipe his
face clean, the only sound being the low,
panting breaths of the four MTF agents.
That was when he saw a shadow move, just ahead
of him, darting between the trees before vanishing
from the view of his optics once again.
It was at least the size of a horse, far bigger
than Alex had been expected, and able to move
around astonishingly fast on its four legs.
“Movement this side,” he announced, alerting
his teammates.
“It’s toying with us,” Sawyer muttered.
“With respect, how’s that possible sir?”
Warren asked.
“It’s an animal, isn’t it?”
“It’s a hunter,” Jones replied.
“We need to move, our visibility’s no
good with all these trees around,” the commander
whispered.
“On my mark, we make our way towards the
town.”
“But, sir, we’ll be sitting ducks down
there, it can flank us from any side,” Warren
argued.
“We’re better off down there, at least
we’d have streetlights to help us see it
coming!”
Alex interjected, mainly just making an excuse
to get as far away from the encroaching entity
as possible.
“This isn’t up for discussion,” Sawyer
said, taking command.
“Head for the town, that’s an order.
On my count, three, two…”
“Contact!”
Jones shouted.
The deafening noise and blinding muzzle flash
of his weapon firing quickly followed as he
sprayed bullets wildly at a shape that was
barrelling through the forest towards the
team.
Alex turned to see what was happening, only
for Sawyer to yell at the top of his voice,
almost drowned out by the gunfire.
“Go, get out of here, now!”
Obeying his orders, Alex turned his heels
and sprinted towards the low orange light
of the nearby town, just visible at the edge
of the tree line.
Warren was next to him, matching his speed,
their heavy tactical gear that was strapped
to their bodies jostling back and forth each
time one foot came down on the forest floor.
Glancing back over his shoulder, Alex saw
Jones had ceased fire and was running up behind
them.
Further back was Sawyer… with The Grinner
bearing down on him.
The commanding officer of Tyrfing Black had
his weapon raised, finger squeezing down on
the trigger.
Every round he fired illuminated part of the
forest for a split second.
Alex couldn’t make out the creature in any
great detail, not while also running further
and further away, increasing his distance
from it.
All he could make out from this far was a
pink, fleshy quadrupedal mass galloping straight
for Sawyer.
He was yelling to get SCP-4910’s attention,
the sound of his war cries carrying over the
night air.
As the three MTF agents broke through the
treeline and reached the edge of the forest,
their commander’s shouts quickly turned
into screams of intense pain and unspeakable
horror, and then fell silent.
Alex wasn’t sure if the creature had attacked
and eaten him, or caused more of those unnatural
teeth to fill Sawyer’s mouth, blocking his
screams permanently.
Reaching the town, every road was completely
deserted, gently lit by the dim glow of orange
streetlights.
Tiny rural stores and independent businesses
had their doors bolted tight, roll-down shutters
locked up for the night, meaning hiding in
one of the buildings wasn’t an option.
Panting, Alex leaned over and put his hands
to his knees, trying desperately to catch
his breath.
“Now what?”
Warren asked, the terror in his voice impossible
to miss.
“That thing’s gonna be here any second.”
“We need to get away from here, as fast
as we can, and send word to the Foundation,”
Alex answered, speaking between deep, breathless
wheezes.
“Tell them we need back up, that this thing
is too dangerous for only three of us to take
on.”
“There may not be enough time for that,”
Jones chimed in, standing a few paces away
from the others.
He had been staring down the long stretch
of the street they had stopped at, frozen
to the spot, barely moving a muscle.
Both Alex and Warren turned to look in the
same direction… and there it was, only a
few feet away under the light of a streetlamp.
It was almost like SCP-4910 was waiting for
them to catch their breath, intelligent enough
to know its hunt wasn’t yet over.
Alex, having now finally got a better look
at the monster, instantly wished he hadn’t.
It made him feel sick, like there was a lump
lodged in the back of his throat.
The Grinner stood atop four pink, sinewy legs,
its body just a formless mass of pure musculature
that looked like it had been sculpted out
of the same tissue that human gums are made
from.
It lacked a neck, instead having a pair of
massive jaws poking out between its front
shoulders, a dark, marble-like eye on either
side of its head.
SCP-4910’s wide, almost crocodilian jaws
parted, showing off what had earned it the
ironic nickname of ‘The Grinner’.
It presented a gaping maw of crooked, uneven
teeth, with more clusters of enamel protruding
from its back, elbows, and head.
These teeth even formed the hooves it walked
on.
At this distance, it was hard to tell if the
sickening yellow coloring of the teeth was
purely because of the streetlights, or that
they had all been stained and covered in plaque.
Alex tried to contain a cough in his throat,
his stomach feeling like it was folding over
itself at the sickening sight of SCP-4910.
He started spluttering, wondering if he was
about to vomit given the lingering feeling
at the back of his throat, like that sensation
one gets when something is forcing its way
up the esophagus.
But it was lodged, the feeling wasn’t coming
up and out of Alex’s throat, it was stuck
there.
By now he was wheezing, desperately trying
to breathe through relentless coughs.
Jones kept his eyes on the creature; it was
pacing slowly towards them now, keeping a
distance but moving like a lion encircling
its prey.
Warren turned and kneeled down to Alex, slapping
him hard on the back, trying to help him cough
up whatever he was practically choking on.
Alex’s eyes started going misty, watering
up and he gasped for air, still feeling that
lingering feeling of being held right at the
edge of being sick.
In a final act of desperation, he jammed his
fingers down his throat, trying to dislodge
or dispel whatever was making him gag.
That was when he felt it, a cluster of little,
solid pieces embedded in the roof of his mouth.
Teeth, teeth that hadn’t been there before,
hadn’t grown naturally but had just sprung
out of his flesh.
And more were growing.
Pain filled his mouth, spreading over Alex’s
entire face as new jagged teeth came bursting
through his gumline, overlapping with his
natural set, tearing his jaw into a wide,
crooked grin.
Looking up through his tear-filled eyes, he
could see the same uneven smile on the face
of the Grinner, as SCP-4910 began dashing
towards its next prey.
Now go and check out “SCP-323 THE WENDIGO
SKULL” and “SCP-2086 MAN EATING BUS”
if you dare to learn about even more malicious
monstrosities, carnivorous creatures and atrocious
anomalies that all seek to do harm to humans!